it's the delicate case someone hid a
wallet in an oven and forgot about it
with predictable results to get to the
bills without cutting them to pieces
frank haired folk specializes in burns
money if the task is to piece together
the chart remnants to find out how much
money was in the wallet the only claim
is it was 220 euros
from Dean was an aberrant condition
there has to be more than 50% left over
for us to be able to reimburse it why
someone could hand in scraps of the same
bill twice they could double their money
that way
he and his 14 fellow specialists
examined some 30 million euros a year in
damaged cash there's no charge for
reimbursement even in such complicated
cases these banknotes have fused with a
wallet they're melted but I still have
to make sure that right-hand sections
are still there only then can we
reimburse the sum no done converter
skill - study head soak works for the
Bundesbank the German central bank's
analysis center these damaged coins were
taken out of circulation no refund no
exchange these rotted banknotes were
buried in a yard he only wanted to keep
them safe from thieves
he'll get his money's worth back just
like those still owning Deutsche marks
this man plays the role of detective for
the department he's out to uncover
counterfeit notes
often he can even tell right off what
workshop produced the bills
failed wrongfully off math counter it
note soft and feel smoother banknote
paper is rough because it's printed on
non commercial paper on pure cotton and
you can feel the difference but to tell
the best forgeries from the originals he
needs technological help only
counterfeits glow under ultraviolet
light and enlargements reveal the
printing errors
some odd cases that are very curious a
300 euro note for instance when there's
no such thing in circulation people will
still accept these banknotes anything
that looks like money will work
someplace or another now Frank head folk
has to deal with scoundrels of a very
different kind mice have looted one
customers hiding-place in the Attic the
speargun invoice that's hard about cases
due to mice is simply that they'll gnaw
out the fibers to use as nesting
material so they carried off somewhere
some with big fog but in this case the
mouse was not greedy hetsig will
eventually piece together half of each
banknote and reimburse the customer